and now Great Moments in unintended
Consequences part one housing costs the
year 2021 the problem rent is expensive
in Saint Paul Minnesota the solution
limit residential rent increases to
three percent a year even if there's a
change in occupancy sounds like a great
idea with the best of intentions what
could possibly go wrong the initiative
did not account for inflation which you
know is kind of a thing and unlike most
Sprint control initiatives the new law
also applies to new apartment buildings
discouraging housing construction and
investment which is why multi-family
building permits are down over 80
percent in St Paul while ramping up in
the rest of the state which explains why
Saint Paul is the patron saint of tent
makers part two Arizona alt fuel the
year 2000 the problem not enough
alternative fuel being used in Arizona
the solution generous tax credits for
new vehicles to incentivize by players
to add an alternative fuel tank sounds
like a great idea with the best of
intentions what could possibly go wrong
the subsidy allowed tens of thousands to
buy fully loaded luxury SUVs at a nearly
50 discount as long as they were
converted to add a secondary one gallon
alternative fuel tank that would likely
never be filled up the plan wound up
costing the state hundreds of millions
and actually increased gasoline
consumption tanks for nothing part three
Georgia ballot access the year 1940 the
problem communists
the solution bar Communists from
appearing on balance sounds
pretty unconstitutional with
intentions what could possibly go wrong
restrictive valid access measures were
codified in 1943 requiring signatures
from five percent of a congressional
district voters later more requirements
were added including forcing signatures
to be notarized and the imposition of
qualifying fees it's now been over 60
years since a third party candidate has
muscled through the restrictions to
appear on the ballot for any
Congressional race in Georgia the
unattended consequence of oh oh right
okay uh yep I get it now okay yep never
mind Great Moments and unintended
consequences good intentions bad results
have an idea for future episodes put it
in the comments we might use it or not
what am I psychic